is Scott Disick dating Bella Thorne it's
kind of fun this is fantastic the 33
year old reality star and the 19 year
old actress were spotted out on a dinner
date and et has the details
their attraction is growing sure seems
like it
Scott and Bella hung out in West
Hollywood Monday night they had dinner
at catch a lei then headed over to the
nice guy sources tell et the pair were
at a table together for an hour but the
night didn't end there
later the duo checked out some live
tunes as a peppermint Club they were
spotted leaving at 1:30 a.m. in Scotts
car are you serious for know this is
crazy
it seems Scott Disick is finally moving
on from his ex Kourtney Kardashian as
for Bella she was most recently linked
to Tyler Posey and Charlie puth here's
what she told et about dating in January
and dating in Hollywood is literally the
worst thing it gets really crazy because
people make it very difficult like if
I'm it photos out with somebody like
immediately I'm their girlfriend and I
moved in with them to Scott and Bella
new couple or just friends let me know
what you think on Twitter
[Music]